[Music]
one of the very first acts that the
current administration has been
vindicated after nearly a year and a
half to the Supreme Court upheld the
constitutionality of the president's
travel ban the left reacted in it's
typically restrained way than a republic
tweeted quote if it wasn't clear before
it should be now Democrats should
prepare to pack the Supreme Court David
J furie is a lawyer and was a foreign
policy advisor to Barack Obama's
presidential campaigns he joins us now
David thanks for coming on so here you
have a band that didn't mention Muslims
that did not restrict immigration from
the biggest Muslim countries that did
restrict immigration from non-muslim
countries like North Korea and yet
somehow was a Muslim ban can we just
admit now that was it probably the
dumbest talking point ever and that it
was a lie you know Tucker I was on your
show exactly one year ago today to argue
about this with you one year ago the
Supreme Court issued its a decision that
overturned the halt on the ban that was
the second ban a lot has changed since
then but in some ways nothing has
changed now the Supreme Court has made
its final ruling on the third ban
now that third ban is different from the
second band and much different from the
first ban but in the end there are many
who still believe that the purpose of
the ban was to ban Muslims from coming
to the country and there is some support
for that so what I think is that this is
still really bad policy for the country
there are some good legal arguments now
that the Supreme Court took hold of and
the majority a very thin majority by the
way five to four you use to rule in
favor of the ban and to support the ban
however this is still bad policy because
we are still landing Muslims we're still
banning lots of Muslims who did who are
not a security threat and we're not
banning many of the Muslims like some
Muslims from some countries who actually
have engaged in terrorist acts here in
the United States so how would we know
for example if immigrant is from
Afghanistan Somalia Syria do we trust
those governments to keep close track of
the records of the people who are coming
here that's a rhetorical question the
answer is obviously not so why would we
even take any risk at all since we don't
know we
no we never will know exactly who they
are well obviously the administration
thinks it knows that's why it's taken
the time to ban people from certain
countries it thinks it can figure out
what country it's problem but don't we
know can we just agree that if you're
coming here from Somalia it doesn't have
a government functional enough to keep
track of who you are and to pass on any
applicable or relevant records about you
it's a dysfunctional place same with
Afghanistan same I would argue Syria
under the the conditions of the Civil
War right now so like who would disagree
with that do we trust the government of
Somalia to tell us the truth actually
even the Trump administration disagrees
with you about Somalia when the trumpet
Minister they may but I'm not you but
they're not here I'm asking but hold on
I'm asking you what do you think of that
I mean do you trust the government of
Somalia to vet for us the people from
small you who come here that's insane
right and I don't wait the Trump
administration thinks is just it's
obviously crazy well I mean we have to
trust somebody
right so when DHS and the X PRIZE I
suppose it doesn't have the State
Department really but when they did a
review they they concluded actually this
administration concluded that Somalia
did have some procedures in place that
warranted not it not to be in the band
then it was put back in the Bayeux and
say wait hold on wait hold on why would
I trust some bureaucrat at the State
Department with my country and my
children like I'm like how would we know
it let's be specific to be honest here
so the State Department I don't care
whose administration it's telling us no
don't worry about it
we trust the governor Somalia why
shouldn't I laugh at them when they say
something so self-evidently
stupid and dishonest to me a couple
reasons first of all all Americans do
deserve to be secure and we need to put
in place things to protect us but with
respect to so I we have many immigrant
that's gonna seek a visa to come here
they are going to go through a review
process and those review processes
generally work and our people here who
review us say generally were applying
for a visa they don't trust the Somalian
government they look at the documents
they do vetting they do an interview oh
do we have a lot of training a lot of
people and the challenge that little
random person oh this is all so stupid
we don't have anybody on the ground in
Somalia honestly how many State
Department employees are vetting the
many hundreds of thousands of Somali
refugees who've come to this country how
many are there in refugee camps in Kenya
or in Somalia hey that's a great move
honestly after thousands of them
yeah actually the interviews don't take
place in Somalia for that reason the the
Somalians wanted means that they have to
go to Djibouti so have to travel to
Djibouti
they have to go to the US Embassy in
Djibouti and they have to go - I know I
know process right there so but but we
can't vet any of it because Somalia is
not a functioning country so actually
none of its vetted it's all make-believe
and bureaucrats under all these
administrations are lying to us and
we're just sort of nodding like sheep oh
I'm sure it's fine it's not fine
actually at all boy and this did you
know that it is fine because we've had
it 30 years - actually they don't say
that good at all no no American has been
killed by a Somalian who came to the
United States right and how much money -
Somali terror groups Al Shabaab have
that you know as flown from Minneapolis
in the last 15 years anyway we're out of
time unfortunately but if you can tell
me how were vetting these people I'd be
assured to know David very great to see
you
Thank you Thank You Tucker